- [Instructor] Let's
say we wanna figure out
what eight divided by 4/10 is.
Pause this video and try to
figure it out on your own
before we do it together.
All right, now one way to approach this is
to think about everything
in terms of tenths.
And why tenths, you ask?
Well, I just described
the second number as 4/10.
So what would eight be in terms of tenths?
Well, we know that one whole
is equal to 10/10,
so eight wholes is going
to be equal to 80/10.
So I could write that down over here.
Instead of eight, I can
write that as 80/10.
And I'm taking 80/10 and
I'm dividing that by,
divided by 4/10.
I'm just writing out, 4/10.
So if I have 80 of something,
and if I'm diving it into groups
of four of that something,
how many equal groups am I going to have?
Well, I'm gonna have 80
divided by four groups,
or 80 divided by four,
eight divided by four.
Actually, let me just write that down.
This is going to be equal to 80 over four
or 80 divided by four.
And eight divided by four is two,
so 80 divided by four is
going to be equal to 20.
So eight divided by 4/10 is equal to 20.
Another way that you
could think about that is
to rewrite eight divided by 4/10
as eight over 4/10.
Over 4/10.
And then if you wanted to rewrite this,
you could say, "Hey, can
I multiply the numerator
"and the denominator by some
quantity that'll get rid
"of the decimal in the denominator?"
Well, I could multiply
the denominator by 10.
And if I don't wanna change
the value of the fraction,
I have to multiply the
numerator by that same amount.
Well, what does that get us?
Well, this is going to be equal to,
in the denominator right over here,
I'm just going to have a four.
So we got rid of the decimal.
In the numerator, I am going to get 80.
So once again, we get 80 over
four, which is equal to 20.
Let's do another example,
but in this case we'll
deal with hundredths.
So let's say we want to figure out
what is 48
divided by 0.24
or 24/100?
Pause this video and
try to figure that out.
All right, well, we can
do something very similar.
This time we're dealing with hundredths,
so we could try to express everything
in terms of hundredths.
So 48 is equal to how many hundredths?
Well, we know that one
is equal to 100/100,
so 48 is going to be equal
to 48 times 100/100.
Maybe I'll just write it like that.
Or you might be able to
say, "Hey, that's 4,800
"or 4,800/100."
So let's just, actually,
I'll write it that way.
This is going to be 4,800/100
divided by, this is 24/100.
24/100.
And so what's that going to be?
Well, same logic as we used up here.
If I have 4,800 of something
or 4,800 of something
and if I'm dividing it into equal groups
of 24 of that something,
well, I'm going to have 4,800
divided by 24 equal groups.
So this is going to be equal to 4,800
over 24.
We could express 4,800 as, of
course, 48 times a hundred.
So this is equal to 48
times 100 over 24.
And of course, you could
view this as the same thing
as this is equal to 48 over 24.
48 over 24, and many of you
might have already done it
in your head, times 100.
What's 48 divided by 24?
Well, that is going to be equal to two.
So two times a hundred is equal to 200.
So this right over here is equal to 200.
You can also do it in this type
or do it similar to the way we did this
where instead of
expressing it out as words,
you could express it as 48 over 24/100.
And instead of multiplying the numerator
and denominator by 10,
maybe you wanna multiply
it by something else
to get whole numbers in both
the numerator and denominator.
Think about that after this video,
and try to work it out that way as well.